[Musica]
[Applauso]
Mia nonna era una contadina nata nel sud
Italia con la sua famiglia coltivava la
terra cosa desiderava mia nonna
Probabilmente di salire al nord e
trovare un lavoro un pochettino meno
faticoso di quello agricolo i nostri
genitori invece cosa desideravano posto
fisso le vacanze in montagna un futuro
sereno per i propri figli
e noi generazioni più giovani cosa
desideriamo una vita un lavoro l'amore
la sopravvivenza su questo pianeta
le differenze fra le generazioni
esistono La mia generazione
in confronto alle generazioni precedenti
è nata e cresciuta con internet e con i
social media
i social media alzi la mano che almeno
una volta desiderato essere qualcun
altro o possedere le cose di qualcun
altro solo perché le ha viste online
funzionano così i social ci fanno
desiderare sempre di più ed è un po'
successo quello che succede quando uno
va in pizzeria e ha in mente che pizza
ordinare ma poi apre il menù e ci sono
20 tipologie diverse
lo psicologo Barry short lo chiama il
paradosso della scelta
all'aumentare delle scelte È sempre più
difficile scegliere perché ci sono
troppe opzioni abbiamo paura di
sbagliare quindi insieme alle scelte
sono aumentati anche i dubbi cosa
dobbiamo desiderare chi dobbiamo essere
trasferirsi non trasferirsi carriera o
amore lavoro o studio
c'era Però un altro problemuccio che
aleggiava già nelle generazioni
precedenti che però non veniva molto
preso sul serio e considerato il
cambiamento climatico
Sì
il clima che cambia le temperature che
sia aumentano le foreste che bruciano le
città che si allagano i ghiacciai che si
sciolgono La mia generazione ha capito
che forse il problema non era tanto cosa
fare da grandi Ma come ci saremmo
arrivati da grandi perché Guardate che
forse tranne anche troppo tempo dovremmo
uscire solo di notte perché le città
saranno così roventi da renderci
impossibile la vita di giorno oppure
potremmo trovare dei nuovissimi viaggi
per esempio quelli nella Venezia
Sottomarina Perché i ghiacciai si sono
sciolti e il livello del mare anche il
mar Mediterraneo sia così alzato da
mettere in difficoltà le città costiere
e poi magari dovremo migliorare Noi
saremo noi a doverci spostare al nord
perché le terre saranno così aride e
incoltivabili da renderci necessario lo
spostamento Per non parlare poi della
biodiversità stiamo minando la
biodiversità vegetale animale del
pianeta Siamo di fronte alla sesta
estinzione di massa la quinta è stata
quella dei dinosauri per lo meno loro si
sono estinti per cause di forza maggiore
non per colpa loro
e quindi
è difficile desiderare
un futuro il futuro delle generazioni
passate nel contesto di crisi climatica
Non so voi ma quando ero piccola Io
facevo costruire i villaggi degli
indiani con i cuscini del divano
costruivo tutto facevo dei villaggi
meravigliosi e poi puntualmente
crollavano e la mamma mi chiamava per
cena Ecco io credo che a un certo punto
la mia generazione si sia resa conto di
come le certezze alcune certezze siano
crollate è successo un po' il famoso
strappo nel cielo di carta
Siamo stati abituati a concepire il
mondo come un grandissimo supermercato
Dai quali Da quale scaffale prendere
qualsiasi cosa quando vogliamo E come lo
vogliamo ed è paradossale perché siamo
passati dall'avere un miliardo di scelte
con l'internet e i social media a non
avere quasi più scelta a causa del
cambiamento climatico
E quindi che facciamo mettiamo la testa
sotto la sabbia come gli struzzi No
perché in primo luogo gli struzzi non
mettono la testa sotto la sabbia in
secondo luogo perché anche se la bassa
Non lo fanno per paura ma lo fanno per
curare le loro uova fanno un gesto di
altruismo per le generazioni future
Eccolo là forse cosa dobbiamo fare
Dobbiamo prendere consapevolezza che le
nostre azioni hanno un impatto su di noi
sul pianeta e sulle generazioni del
futuro
non è facile capirlo ma è possibile ed è
possibile farlo a tantissimi livelli a
livello governativo a livello aziendale
e anche a livello personale
le nostre azioni singole possono
migliorare la situazione per esempio
possiamo mangiare più sostenibile
possiamo vegetalizzare la nostra dieta
perché le proteine animali soprattutto
la carne rossa hanno un enorme impatto
in termini di consumo di acqua consumo
di suolo emissioni di gas clima
alteranti quindi scegliere di mangiare
più vegetale E magari da agricoltura
anche rispettosa e cosa buona e giusta
potremmo vestire più sostenibile sono
certa che tutti i nostri armadi compreso
il mio sono pieni di vestiti di scarpe
di accessori spesso da Brand di fast
fashion o da Brand che non sono molto
attenti alla sostenibilità e l'industria
Tessile è una delle più inquinanti sia
per il consumo di acqua per le pratiche
agricole per la fine che fanno i nostri
vestiti che vengono dispersi nelle
discariche di mezzo mondo Per non
parlare poi dell'aspetto etico delle
condizioni lavorative di chi fa i nostri
vestiti in condizioni non propriamente
positive
Eppure potremmo anche usare energia più
sostenibile
accendere la televisione il avere il
frigo accendere il forno alla Lavatrice
lavastoviglie sono tutti gesti
quotidiani parli facciamo tutti Pensate
se tutti questi gesti potessero essere
possibili grazie alle energie
rinnovabili
all'energia che provengono dal sole
dall'acqua e dal vento e non dei
combustibili fossili che sono dei
maggiori responsabili dell'aumento di
CO2 in atmosfera
Potremmo bere più sostenibile
pensate che noi italiani abbiamo l'acqua
più pulita e più controllata l'acqua del
sindaco di tutta Europa però un terzo
delle persone ha paura dell'acqua del
rubinetto e più della metà delle
famiglie italiane Compra l'acqua in
bottiglia aumentando i rifiuti plastici
che poi magari vanno a finire pure negli
oceani
possiamo muoverci più sostenibile
partendo da una cosa facile facile
andare a piedi oppure usare il Car
Sharing in città o per esempio usare il
treno negli spostamenti più lunghi usare
la bicicletta per le commissioni
potremmo comprare più sostenibile
comprare di meno comprare usato riparare
riutilizzare Io faccio sempre l'esempio
del trapano Io non ho bisogno di un
trapano Io ho bisogno del buco nel muro
perché non istituiamo il trapano del
condominio per esempio E perché non
evitiamo di riempire così tanto tutti
quei carrelli di prodotti con gli sconti
del Black Friday di cose che
probabilmente neanche ci servono più di
tanto
Insomma bisogna cambiare le nostre
abitudini e non è per niente facile
Perché l'essere umano di base è un
essere abitudinario
è difficile cambiare le abitudini Perché
il nostro cervello è settato
in maniera il risparmio energetico
cambiare le abitudini ci deve stabilizza
però vi assicuro che se cominciamo a
capire le cause le conseguenze di quello
che sta succedendo al nostro clima e
quindi a tutti noi le cambiamo le
abitudini e ve lo dico per esperienza
e perché no
potremmo riuscire anche a utilizzare i
famosi social media per diffondere
queste nuove abitudini se sono così
potenti da farci desiderare di essere
qualcun altro o farci desiderare le cose
di qualcun altro perché non potrebbero
veicolare e diffondere questo messaggio
e quindi come il battito d'ali di una
farfalla New York può causare un tifone
a Pechino così le nostre azioni singole
hanno un enorme importanza e possono
causare dei cambiamenti lungo tutto il
sistema nel corso del tempo e la domanda
qua che spesso mi viene fatta Eh sì ma
le mie azioni singole che cosa possono
fare poco no
assolutamente no perché pensare che
l'ambientalismo individuale sia una cosa
che non ha senso è sbagliato perché è
vero il contrario
è vero il contrario Perché uno le azioni
dei singoli possono avere un effetto
sulle decisioni politiche due perché
i cambiamenti della società si creano a
partire dai singoli individui i
cambiamenti
collettivi partono da noi Noi siamo
persone
i governi sono fatti da persone le
aziende sono fatte da persone il mondo è
fatto da persone
cosa dobbiamo fare se non cercare
di desiderare un mondo più sostenibile
perché non solo è difficile desiderare
il futuro delle generazioni passate
perché il posti fissi non esistono più
le coppie scoppiano i social media ci
hanno messo troppe scelte troppi dubbi
nella mente ma perché se continuiamo
così il pianeta
si farà male anzi noi ci faremo male
perché il pianeta vivrà benissimo anche
senza la specie umana
dobbiamo cambiare le nostre abitudini e
dobbiamo cercare di interiorizzare il
rispetto per l'altro per gli ecosistemi
per il pianeta per noi stessi dobbiamo
cercare di modificare le azioni
quotidiane gli stili di vita in modo più
rispettoso ad avere un meno impatto
sugli altri e quindi non dobbiamo forse
più desiderare solo un futuro dobbiamo
desiderare un futuro più sostenibile
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]